there's a reason that women live longer
mark let me tell you it is because we
are stronger and we are happier at the
end of the day than most men and that is
factual and you know it
when when men are married to women who
scream like you they just want to die
sooner
when you have any when you have women
going around you wanted a tattoo on your
penis i wanted to put a tattoo if i
would get one there that would say buyer
beware
what are you going to say i'm impressed
there's enough room
i tell you
and i can assure you
that he knows there is
and you're still looking like cher
well she looks good for her age unlike
some people
i worked way too friggin hard for this a
lot of people work really really hard
for their dreams but it's not meant for
everybody that's why you use auto-tune
and i don't
actually
this movie coming out yes title
undetermined at this point chairman of
the board oh
all right do something with that you
freak
i i've got the board to spell b-o-r-e-d
but the most annoying one i get is when
i've set up a joke just about through
the punchline and someone goes it's all
invariably it's the same thing so it's
where's ireland where's ellen it's not
my like bet noir it's just a bit
annoying where's ellen
he's at your house [ __ ] your dad
getting pretty burned yeah well you know
just earlier this afternoon i found
something on my back that looks like it
made
oh yeah
well that this part's true yeah
what you should probably do is uh
lay down and just let the sun cook it
off oh that that seems like an excellent
idea
but i'm not as dumb as i look
how could you be
last week we had mariah carey here in
the studio you did how was she doing
well she was doing great oh great yes
it's great what i'm curious about what
do you think of her what do i think of
her yes
i don't think of her i
no you're pretty rock and roll and
countdown isn't how would you make this
show kind of more more kind of cool
different host
last time at the first debate we had
millions of people uh fact-checking so i
expect we'll have millions more
fact-checking uh because you know it is
uh
it's just awfully good that someone
with the temperament of donald trump is
not in charge of the law in our country
because you'd be in jail secretary
clinton
[Applause]
how did you get into your first um
by the way do you live with your parents
is that true yes
is that common in india for older
children to live with their parents
it's fine to live with your parents
because um it's also common in india
that we don't have to take appointments
with our parents to meet for dinner
everyone loves a good comeback story
right
seabiscuit the mighty ducks robert
downey jr
rocky yes kim kardashian kim well
in the video she gets she gets come on
her back i think
he has a tractor and he smashes up old
cars just to get
attention out of him did you ever run up
to someone and say hey how did you get
so rich and the woman said by writing on
my mom's coattails and you said melissa
this is my show
and i think we're going to end the
interview right now don't get so [ __ ]
smart
i came in and he was supposed to be the
uh
my uh kind of my guide through snl and
it turned out that
he is a
sister i'm not gonna guide any lady
through comedy that would take me uh
first of all i'd have to figure out how
a lady could do comet
and england skipper andrew strauss
arrived in london proudly showing off
the little urn they'll spend four days
at home before flying out for the world
cup and belinda i just can't understand
how something so small can be so
impressive well mark you would know
about that thank you very much but are
you still considered the fat guy
when you go to a party or anything
because i run into that a whole lot i'm
the fat one
okay so does that just are you the fat
guy in hollywood still or or does
everybody like look at you and they're
like oh wow you know this is great now
you're healthy uh do you have any other
questions that are smart you have some
shock value to you i mean you're on the
cover of your book you're wearing a fur
and you knew that there were probably
the animal rights action you know this
whole interview is becoming a defensive
interview
are you wearing leather shoes yeah shut
up
you know what i mean i don't want to
hear you're wearing fur you're wearing
heaven not an actor
you're eating chicken you're eating meat
i don't want to hear this nonsense why
should your right to freedom of speech
trump a trans person's
right not to be offended because in
order to be able to think you have to
risk being offensive i mean look at the
conversation we're having right now
you know like you're certainly willing
to risk offending me in the pursuit of
truth why should you have the right to
do that it's been rather uncomfortable
i've seen your new show where you sit in
the hot tub
your body ain't that good you can just
walk around without your shirt off
if we're ever going to talk about bodies
i want you not to be the one to bring
that conversation
all right if you don't get out of here
shaped like a bean bag they got that in
this time when you snuck into the room
to see what the i sneaked into the room
snuck isn't a word conan and you went to
harvard and you should know that
[Applause]
snuck past and past part of sneak
my my wife calls it's like since when
did you become the fat guy on that show
it's it's great it's the same uh
[Applause]
what are you afraid of
well i was gonna go with flying but i
think i'll go with um girls over 12.
[Applause]
when's the comedy on
it says if you want my comeback you'll
have to scrape it off your mom's teeth
nearly 200 dead 14 000 who are sick
millions as you witness who are scared
right now what do you say to americans
who are watching you right now who are
scared
i say that you're a terrible reporter
that's what i say
[Music]
120 minutes i'm thurston moore of sonic
youth interviewing beck who's right here
beside me back uh i sort of wanted to
ask you some questions about uh
you know where you're from and who
exactly you are and i can't seem to get
any straight answers out of anybody who
seems to know you but uh
what exactly is your real name is it
beck were you christened beck
all right have you seen the movies like
you have to you have to know all the
movies is that i've watched some of them
yeah you know some of them
any clunkers anything you like you don't
like that
they're good there's some good ones yeah
yeah what are you trying to get me to
say man
well any club anyone you said it in my
movies
that goes without saying but anything
anything
hey you did a movie too i don't i know
i'm not i know i did a lot your movie
went straight to audio
you
look like a less hot version of obama
you're like obama but not as hot
the only reason
that you're saying that
because you know i slept with your
mother
i need to watch this movie
you haven't seen spiderman
i haven't seen the falcon oh no there
isn't one sorry
you go in the water or the ocean a lot
are you because some people hate the
ocean i like the ocean you i do i like
the ocean very much yeah
that's great you must do you float a lot
in the ocean
sure
what do you think
it might be that cast iron heart
i've admitted that you're lazy i think
you've read six books in your life i've
read six six what kind of a woman would
be attracted to you do you think
well i have a lot of money
and i'm sure i mean i would hope that if
i were a student of dr peterson that he
would refer to me as a
as she and wouldn't have a problem with
that
um but at the end of the day you know a
personal pronoun preference still is a
preference for what language other
people use and at the end of the day i
don't uh have ultimate control over what
dr peterson
what the language he chooses to use or
anybody else for that matters that's
that's up to them okay let me find out
that arises let me find out if she were
a student of yours what would you call
her
she you would okay perfect transition
to charlie sheen because you did his
roast at the height of his whatever you
want to call it meltdown yeah let's
watch
it
anthony we're literally watching you
because we couldn't hear a word you said
can you repeat something that you said
about charlie sheen i don't even
remember that this is a great operation
you guys are running here by the way i'm
gonna say that i don't know how you
screwed that up
someone had to hit play if he can
recreate the svu donald the charlie
sheen thing and we play the video with
no audio yeah go ahead go ahead charlie
sheen every minute of your life is like
watching fox 5 news in the morning
it's completely worthless
go see me at the american comedy company
7 and 9 30.